swimming with dolphins is a popular
activity for many tourists in Hawaii but
a proposed federal rule could lead to a
dramatic change the National Oceanic and
Atmospheric Administration or NOAA wants
to ban boats and swimmers from getting
too close to Hawaiians spinner dolphins
Carter Evans traveled to Oahu where
concerns about the animals health could
hurt the tourist industry we were the
toward tracking Hawaiian spinner
dolphins off the west coast of Oahu it
looks like pretty close to 100 dolphins
the Hawaiian Islands are one of the few
places native to Hawaii these spinner
dolphins are a smaller species about
four feet long they're social animals
known for their acrobatic behaviors in
the water they seem curious and approach
us several swim right underneath don't
push toward him but our guy Jenna Morris
is serious about keeping our distance
you don't actually want people touching
the dolphins no I think the hardest
singlehandedly hardest part of my job is
managing expectations that people have
be a stealthy as possible
current law prohibits harassing dolphins
but it doesn't limit how close you can
get to them and many people have taken
advantage online videos show swimmers
frolicking with the dolphins and even
tried to pet them I do think that this
human activity is raising their stress
levels NOAA fisheries biologist and
Garrett says spinner dolphins are
nocturnal and feed at night they come
close to shore during the day to rest in
protected shallow waters and the tour
boats are a disturbance what we're
seeing is that their rest times are
shortening the dolphins we're concerned
with maybe not feeding as well maybe too
tired to do the foraging that they need
to and are perhaps not nurturing their
young in the same way that they ought to
Garrett says over time this could lead
to a decrease in the population NOAA is
now proposing changes to the current law
that would keep people and boats at
least 50 yards from the dolphins is it
unusual for them to come right up to you
know
dolphins are very curious animals by
Nature Victor Lozano is one of the many
tour operators against the proposed rule
he says it would be difficult to keep
the dolphins away from the boats and
hard for tourists to see them at that
distance which could hurt business but
he agrees there are too many tours and
not every tour company is following the
rules we're all making a living we need
to protect it we need to make sure that
we're responsible how we're viewing
these animals I don't think this
tourists suffering even right now as
long as everyone listens Sabrina Krantz
and her daughter try to swim with the
dolphins whenever they visit Hawaii this
time may be their last
what is it about getting up so close to
the dolphins is so special it's just
being in nature in its pure form you get
to see them do their thing it's just
beautiful for CBS this morning Carter
Evans oh wow thanks Carter